in relation to the process I'm focused
on delivering for the British people do
my job at home safely but what I will
say is that in my view I'm confident
that nothing untoward has happened what
would you welcome an investigation into
this have you spoken to the Prime
Minister would you welcome one as I said
I'm focused on working as Home Secretary
that's why I'm here I've met with
victims today I'm making a big
announcement today I'd appreciate the
focus on an announcement which is
standing up for victims and survivors in
relation to the speeding ticket and my
fine and points I'm very confident
very funny on this project but this is
really important because you you've
broken rules before you've had a
resigner for breaking the ministerial
code you've admitted now to to Breaking
or having a speeding fight you've
accused of breaking the code for a
second time how could a look is it for a
senior politician one of the senior
politicians of the country to be viewed
as a constant rule breaker
I got a speeding ticket I paid the fine
I took the points in my view nothing
Untold has happened thank you